the american beauty industry is
constantly changing but it's clear one
trend
is here to stay the popularity of asian
beauty trends
i think that for you know many
generations there's been a fascination
with asian skin care because i think
mostly honestly because of genetics
a lot of us typically have pretty nice
skin but definitely looking back in
history as well
for me growing up though i felt like a
total
outsider within the mainstream beauty
industry
to the point of where i never saw
someone who looked like me
in a beauty advertisement or fashion or
anything else
many people in the aapi community grew
up feeling underrepresented in this
industry
but with trends like gua sha rice water
jade rollers and sheet masks blowing up
on social media
asian beauty is having a huge moment
we were seeing that initial explosion of
the k-beauty trend
in the states it's a movement that's
really infiltrated every medicine
cabinet across the country in so many
different ways
so your favorite brand that has a sheet
mask k-beauty inspired
your favorite brand that uses fermented
ingredients and that you have in your
makeup bag once again k beauty inspired
so
the inspiration has really evolved in
such a way where it's everywhere and i
think that's really meaningful for us to
see how it's just irrevocably changed
the landscape of beauty and skin care
south korea is among the top 10 global
beauty markets
worth more than 13 billion dollars as of
2017.
meanwhile facial skin care is projected
to be worth more than seven billion
dollars in 2020.
in korea they say that your skin
reflects your mental estate
i think so many both
companies brands influencers just
everyone in the beauty industry to some
degree
is is adjacent to these
inspirations from asia the beauty
industry um
has sometimes not been great at paying
homage to
the origins of things and so you
mentioned before you know gua sha
and jade rollers and all these other you
know rice water have become quite
popular
and so a lot of times these things end
up getting kind of co-opted
by other brands without the homage being
paid
to its origin and so i would just remind
everybody to make sure you know that
we're not just appropriating things but
that we are truly
paying respect to what came before it
especially if you're a brand
that is leveraging the asian heritage
um elements like guasha or any other
sort of inspirations
it's important to tell the story
i think that's been sometimes a hit or
miss type of thing we've seen
brands that told amazing stories in the
context the background of why
and and why they are actually leveraging
this for their brand
but we've also seen brands that have not
and i think that is definitely a huge
opportunity
and without that context you know people
might not really understand
if even if it's um as a product of asian
heritage
or if it's inspired from it so i think
acknowledging that
celebrating it telling the story giving
the context
is the most important some of the other
things that the brands can also do
is think about how actions can
be taken according to a study titled
stop
aapi hate national report there were
nearly 3
800 hate incidents against asian people
from march 2020
to february of 2021. nearly
70 of the victims were asian women one
of the big things within this past year
with the pandemic and this whole rise in
racism
has been this feeling that the aapi
community feels invisible
and so we want the beauty industry to
make sure that we don't feel
invisible as well i think it's hard for
people sometimes to make that connection
between
representation and seeing someone in a
magazine cover or an
advertisement and racist attacks
right they seem so far removed but
actually when you zoom out and look at
representation
on a larger level what's happening is
that when you
are not represented as a group as a
marginalized group
it's very easy to be dehumanized given
the clear impact
that asian beauty has made on the
industry at large
i think it's really crucial that these
brands are also in the community is also
being supported and i think
recently influencers and brands have
been
even more cognizant about really making
sure to provide the right cultural
context and transparency around origins
around education on what's being used
and why
and it's more important than ever to
your point during a time where we're
seeing such a
big surge of api
hate unfortunately that this type of
action becomes
even more important than ever because
beauty the beauty industry and
inclusivity in the beauty industry has
been such a conversation
and it's amazing that these trends and
these cultural traditions are being
represented i do think that the industry
as a whole
has made great strides but i do think
it's our
opportunity and our responsibility
honestly to kind of open people's eyes
to different things